we were once a peaceful race it might
have been worth Optimus Prime staying
dead in the last movie so that he
couldn't narrate the next one opening
flashback brought to you by the Peter
Jackson school of beginning movies our
defeat was all but dirty the people who
saw the first two movies already know
this and the people who showed up for
the third without seeing the first two
don't care
this scene depicts the last time people
who watch the sky for a living ever did
their jobs this ship which was shot on
Cybertron doesn't actually crash from
its damage until Earth's moon gets in
its way
Abraham Zapruder was always following
the president wasn't it movie Forrest
Gump's JFK into the film because movies
about transforming alien robots need all
the authenticity they can computer
generate real JFK was quite the
transformer himself so it seems discount
faked moon landing also did we have to
relive the events of the entire moon
landing could we have just started right
here and went straight to the part that
is so important to the third
Transformers film you were dark on the
rock if he's on the far side of the Moon
why can NASA still talk to him just fine
does Sam have a chocolate coated cock or
something why the babes want to bang
this guy scene does not contain it ah
Who am I kidding even I can find
something to enjoy in this scene Michael
Bay directed the movie but Tim Burton
directed the photograph Sam's parents
are still in these movies no one said
this movie was subtle well you have to
cut these robots a break there are no
female robots except but that is about
Lucas bought from the last movie
transformers are like the Smurfs and she
was the Smurfette and she's dead now
fresh flowers of the prop masters best
friend oh great we're back at this again
only they flipped it I can't wait to see
who says at first but and the hound
ha ha foreshadowing the fact that the
character in this movie that is voiced
by Spock goes crazy also what a stupid
thing to foreshadow
just like the last guy let's face it it
was Michael Bay who did the dumping
bumblebee were sad you mean like
bumblebee in the first movie when Sam
first met him car won't start cliche and
good thing Sam's parents showed up ten
days early so that he could get to the
job interview
in the years since our arrival he's just
gonna start narrating again like we
didn't just sit through 14 minutes of
movie earth has seen much change Energon
detectors guard its cities not only in
the United States apparently because the
Decepticons show up wherever they damn
well please everywhere else in the world
in this movie let's not piss off just
one Middle Eastern country let's piss
off all of them Transformers fool the
first checkpoint soldiers with a decoy
car but then decide ok let's just kill
the arguably innocent humans at the
second checkpoint the facility's name is
Chernobyl here we go dragging Chernobyl
into this that thing melted down in 1986
and it's been toxic to every movie it's
been in ever since three movies in and
the humans are still wasting precious
ammunition firing human bullets at alien
transformers Optimus Prime is fine just
chillin and drivin while the Decepticon
destroys the entire building so helpless
after two movies of seeing every kind of
transformer imaginable Linux is still
astonished when he sees a slightly
different transformer that is shockwave
feel free to masturbate it's possible
character living in sci-fi universe
declares something impossible cliche
this is an engine park from a long-lost
Autobot command is everything in these
movies have to be long-lost can't
anything just be recently lost or always
unlost
none of the Autobots are army guys here
these bullets being fired job interview
montage why was the potential employer
has inside information that the FBI was
looking for Sam at one point but not the
inside information that's because he was
a friend to the alien transformers who
saved earth and that's all that expunged
well obviously not was Christopher
Walken not available to take this bullet
for John Malkovich world's most famous
extra takes his time crossing the office
to maximize screen time also Catherine
Keener isn't possessing John Malkovich
to have sex with Cameron Diaz in this
scene uncredited Gary Busey takes
picture for John Malkovich it's funny
because the Department of Health and
Human Services does so little for
America that their building can just be
used as a secret nest headquarter when
the NSA wants funding they call me new
important bad government character is
conveniently giving her character
description and bio to some dude on the
other end of the phone when we meet her
if I told you you're about to see a
movie with Frances McDorman John
Malkovich and John Turturro
you probably think along the lines of a
Coen Brothers film right do you know how
much money I would pay to see the Cohens
direct a Transformers movie all the
money all right guys
decepticon dad gilsu except you will
mindlessly fire four days into his face
and he won't die so it's pretty
worthless
oh well training also there are next to
no opportunities where the army guys
will be on top of a Decepticon and slide
down into position to shoot it this way
except when the movie and probably puts
them in that position
my name's Buell not to be confused with
cue from the Bond films because that
would be ripping those movies off allow
me to please introduce to you the NASA
founders and Buzz Aldrin must have been
waiting for their cue to dramatically
walk in oh man they drank Buzz Aldrin -
this didn't think the ship's name was
the ark because we've run out of names
to call things let's just steal from the
Bible the great sentinel prime another
old ass long dead transformer man after
the fallen and jet fire in the last
movie not to mention the robot angel
primes in the heaven vision I'm ancient
transformer doubt three movies in then
they still think we care about Sam's
love life which means he will not be the
coolest guy ever look at them curves
okay we know you hate Megan Fox do we
have to spend the whole movie telling
her how unacceptable she is even robots
have to look like Lawrence of Arabia
when visiting the Middle East yeah
better take that off it was just now
starting to look silly slime robot he
gave you a car dylan gives Carly a car
the exact moment Sam became jealous of
the guy which triggers a fight about it
which means lucky us what does this girl
know about paying dues for anything
everyone who isn't needed for the next
scene convenient that gets off the
elevator at once laying deep Wang deep
Wang if you say it three times in a
mirror it becomes less racist of all the
bathrooms on all the floors in this
super huge mega office building the boss
picks the one Sam is having a non-gay
bathroom stall fight with another dude
in because comedy and the Energon
detectors took a smoke break when this
guy came into the states Laserbeak was
given explicit orders to kill all his
human helpers and he's done so except
with Wang because Wang is played by an
actor that demands more screen time I
guess it's not like Megatron said kill
them all except Wang because he has a
few more important tasks to do for us
kai falling out of a window passes by a
meeting in progress cliche this is
exceedingly Japanese that's racist
Laserbeak somehow made it out of Lange's
office walked down a floor hopped onto
the copier table and changed into a
copier without being seen also this is a
terrible disguise if you're planning on
not being discovered if you can
transform into a copier you should be
able to make copies also this guy pushes
a button so this Decepticon says let's
expose ourselves and start killing right
this second I mean this is the same
transformer that just made Wang's death
look like a suicide
because
why again unlike the last movie Sam is
totally worthless in this one so kill
him already
I guess Laserbeak gave up I'll remind
you that these transformers are made of
metal that can withstand missiles so I'm
not buying that he's hurt what a faker
Sam would definitely be dead right now
if these guys really don't know who he
is also Sam suddenly gets the strength
to tackle a trained military dude even
though throughout all these Transformers
movies he's never been the physical type
military guys who have no idea who Sam
is wrestle with him instead of just
putting him down immediately or shooting
it as far as they know he's a crazy
person trying to attack the military
base also this is why an urban nest
headquarters is the stupidest idea ever
because one transformation and the whole
city sees it mean boss lady who hates
Sam and hates that Sam is here decides
to just warn him not to say anything and
lets him in the girlfriend remain also
Sam just happens to show up at the exact
moment Optimus is about to revive
Sentinel Prime these things run on
Energon and he's out of it that's
another thing
Energon was created by blowing up suns
with that machine from the last movie
but that machine wasn't used for
thousands of years and then it got
destroyed so how does any transformer
have enough Energon left to live it's
the great matrix of leadership it's a
key that turns on the machine that blows
up the suns but as it turns out you only
need to use the key to get it a
transformer running so I don't know why
they bothered wasting time blowing up
suns
you are home well earth home but yeah
you saved five of them including the
control pillar alien technobabble it
defies the laws of physics hey dude
they're not our laws physics laws apply
to the whole universe oh man they
dragged poor alan tudyk into this didn't
they you owed your information with
Simmons in this movie there's now pretty
much no reason why Sam would have to
trust Bruce with transformer secrets
just so he could get information about
hwang but the movie needed to find a way
to keep Malkovich in it somehow so this
when it's hiding in America be hiding
job then Carly gets her hair done and
jumps out of her white dress into this
blue one by the time Sam runs upstairs
to explain why all the covert stuff is
going on downstairs okay movie hints at
Carly's dead brother out of nowhere one
hour into the picture is it weird if I
kind of want Megan Fox back exactly how
many Autobots are gonna be allowed to
work with Sam and is not legal not
sanctioned investigation because it's
why the hell not very I just picked up
Sentinel Optimus him
what the hell is going on sentinels just
driving around on the road and why does
Optimus ten minutes behind and don't you
want to hide Sentinel successful
director rips off the highway scene from
every movie he's ever done any of these
three two-hour plus movies ever explain
where the new bad transformers in each
movie keep coming from no one in the
cars ahead is frightened of all the
destruction happening behind them right
now also why did the Decepticons wait
until now to try and kidnap Sentinel
they had plenty of chances right after
he was survived is it because Sam
finally figured out what they want to do
with him and the plot only moves
whenever Sam figures out something good
thing you slung that Decepticon into the
innocent driver there won't have to
worry about him anymore these movies are
all over the place with what weapons do
and do not cause damage and transformers
robot blood splatter I would say Michael
Bay is paying homage to predator here
but I mean this is Michael Bay we're
talking about he only pays homage to his
own penis
metal-on-metal destruction is better
when you have no clue what's going on
autobot protecting earth is addictive
earth's doors a deal had to be made with
Megatron signal prime turns out to be
the bad guy which all the 11-year olds
in the audience found surprising also
this makes loads of no sense if a deal
was made why did the Decepticons shoot
Sentinel Prime down during the war were
they hoping that he would crash land on
the moon and then 50 years later come up
with his convoluted plot to get the
pillars back the far out of here
hey Optimus decided to show up what
stuff has he'd been doing this whole
time he was only 10 minutes behind for
some stupid reason that is totally
unclear the East Africa notes while this
was going on his whole life is this
right here where does he have to be
other than right here take a look
optimus correct dude soccer what yeah
you set him up I'll now come down
Michael Bay hates America did they open
the space bridge so that some
Decepticons buried on the moon could use
it to come to earth that's the moon
right and they can fly it's not like
they needed a ride
setting the lets Optimus Liv and Optimus
just gives up fighting him afterwards
not time for the climax yet I guess nice
reveal but you clearly established in
the last movie that bumblebee and the
other Autobots would be able to tell the
hot girlfriends car was an evil
Decepticon all along
also Sentinel Prime has revealed as evil
Patrick Dempsey's revealed as evil and
now the 200,000 other cars revealed as
evil this movie has surprise evil
character reveal itis had my eye on you
for years that's why I went through all
this trouble of giving your girlfriend a
job to get to you rather than just
giving you a job in the first place
hilarious physical comedy moment but he
was told to do one thing get to optimus
and ask a question so showing the
Decepticons all this little routine
isn't good as same as girlfriend
or make me enjoy the movie let me handle
EPS just shrugs off the weirdness and
assume Sam is simply a crazy dick
hitting all the Intel on the table this
is a flimsy excuse to shoehorn this
character Mac into the movie this world
views this fired agent as a crazy person
not a reliable source of Intel
helicopter blades slowed down to be in
time with the music cliche movie thinks
will buy that they killed the Autobots
nonsense one hour before the movie ends
just in case you confused it with
Chicago South Africa can fall henchman
hacks bad guys cell phone camera for
live video feed and doesn't even need
Morgan Freeman's help to do it you're
not going alone
that's right Tyreese you act I should
get out of that reaction shot you see
they can't rebuild without a slave way
before well I think Kant is a pretty
subjective choice of word there and
surely they could just have taken a long
time they're shipping the planet here
what also this has got to be one of the
dumbest plans in the history of movies
what's on Cybertron that the
Transformers absolutely need to survive
or to feel comfortable how can you
expect the human slaves to adapt to an
entirely different atmosphere also why
use the space bridge to move the planet
instead of just jumping through it and
poof you're back on Cybertron hell you
can bring your slave labor force through
the space bridge too but an entire
planet because unless Cybertron is
nearly identical to Earth in size and
mass I think it's gonna throw off
something in the solar system just by
taking over its spot in the galaxy the
red one there controls the rest wow
thanks for all that helpful information
evil I had expositional how does he do
it movie turns into a trailer of itself
I realize the Decepticons probably view
them as lost leaders but Chicago is a
huge city and they're just killing tons
and tons of slave labor for a show of
force that exactly zero people on earth
need to see to believe the Decepticons
are deadly also I'm all for seeing the
destruction of Chicago but can't we just
let the Cubs finish the job they started
Cosi melancholy pop song plays over
carnage scenes so our subconscious will
remember it's all fake worldwide
domination starts in Chicago for some
reason and no other city also why
destroy Chicago again was there a reason
to lay waste to it the kid went wicked
eh this is the third movie and this
guy's been working with the kid in all
three of them for him to continue
mispronouncing the name is just
insulting at this point to the audience
shocker
also Energon detectors decided to take
another crucial smoke break in order to
not notice the Autobots still on earth
also I'm glad Optimus came back to save
the day but how do you know exactly
where Sam was there was just a chance
meeting which would probably make it
worth - since NASCAR BOTS for today in
the name of freedom we take sub console
to avow G I'm really glad you're alive
Optimus and taking the battle to them
but honestly did you have to wait while
the Decepticons slaughtered millions of
innocent Chicagoans before showing up to
take the battle to them we waitin in the
first booster rocket to separate because
one booster rocket can hold several
large transformers if you forget about
impossible our only chance is the
element of surprise
you know where to look for the element
of surprise um no she totally sees him
immediately how stupid do you think your
audience is why does Laserbeak still
hanging around Patrick Dempsey Megatron
said they were done with that insect so
is it just in case Sam showed up which
no one at all thought would happen is
Sam showing up at this apartment to
confront humans somehow a problem for
the big Decepticon plan sure just drop
him you have weapons but let gravity
decide this well someone seen back to
the future - what is Laserbeak doing
wrestling Sam everyone's gonna survive
this so what's the point
Dillon suddenly has super jumping skills
and look at these bridges mcdreamy's not
making that jump even with Jesse Owens
legs of course you do one shot so we
need one shots all we need cliche earn
that paycheck Tyrese
they got my trailer I need that flight
tech moment you haven't needed the
trailer wants this whole trilogy but now
you absolutely need that crap props
proclaim hi everyone my name is Michael
Bay all I know how to do is take other
movie moments throw them in a blender
and serve up the sludge that comes out
why do the Autobots ever shoot these
useless regular bullets at Decepticons
Decepticons monitor all airspace except
this one side of Willis Tower also
Willis Tower
Sears Tower forever helicopters make it
all the way to Willis Tower after a
brief firefight because Decepticons just
give up for weird stretches of time
it's a weapons to choose from to stop
this helicopter I choose the buzzsaw
realize that as humans in this situation
you have to do something right but what
the hell good do these guys think
they're gonna do in this fight there's
the city of Chicago wasting taxpayer
dollars again by running street lamps in
broad daylight easiest targets to hit
ever still misses only the nameless
soldiers we don't care about get shot
out of the sky shooting at the building
the Decepticons somehow know that Sam
and crew are in this building but
decides shooting it in half it's the
best option rather than shooting at the
floor they're on also instead of
finishing the job they just let it hang
on its axis and make the whole operation
pointless also if they were gonna
destroy Chicago for no reason why not
destroy all the buildings within sight
line of the pillars they went through
all this trouble of wrecking the city
but left convenience everywhere also
collapsing building with heroes inside
takes its sweet time falling over for
some reason come on this do didn't even
trying to hide he obviously knows that
they're in here but decides to
investigate rather than blasting the
hell out of them also Decepticon decides
to hunt for humans as if there's an
invisible wall between him and all the
columns they're hiding behind that guy
gets distracted by a moving object
cliche this Decepticon looks exactly
like Megatron and Starscream heroes
survive Decepticon attack and skyscraper
by utilizing time-tested method of
jumping out the window
conveniently hanging life-saving wires
are convenient yeah that guy's gonna die
let's pan away from him how could
everyone possibly be okay you jackass
almost all the robots in these movies
have some sort of cool name but here's
driller BOTS
ladies and gentlemen shockwave tries
more of the building destruction
strategy to kill the humans lord knows
it's his best option right now and all
out of to give them out the building in
this movie that defied gravity physics
and all the other known laws of anything
why did you even make this bit
live-action no also not only is that a
no but even if he was able to grab her
that arms coming off that beautiful
beautiful arm a fuck has he been this
whole time Optimus takes massive breaks
and shows up way too late to everything
oh yeah then we'll use a space bridge to
bring Cybertron and Earth's position
thing I wonder why they didn't start
doing this 20 minutes ago finally we see
the rest of the world in this plan but
these cities didn't need to be destroyed
for some reason what exactly did you
sign up for considering you have an m249
wrapped around your shoulder this
asshole know where Sam was also you had
the element of surprise and you blew it
I'd be upset that Sam somehow survives
all this crashing and flinging around
but honestly he's already a ragdoll at
this point where is this asshole been
all this time
Monsoor capture capture no those four
Autobots are dead right because any evil
alien Roma or lure worth assault is
killing Autobots at this point not
taking prisoners I mean right see if you
can hack into the bridge Oh bridges I
mean six graders can hack into that
should be that's child's play that the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few
discount Star Trek bridge down to dick
ex machina okay but you only open the
space bridge how did you tell the entire
planet of Cybertron it was time to move
through it are you think they're going
to kill us after waiting all this time
why were they waiting for Sam to show up
as a witness
thankfully the Decepticons execute the
Autobots and in order that allows
bumblebee to live also executions
require just the right location before
you can go through with it
why is bumblebee just taking this three
entire movies have taught us that
whatever character development he has
it's that he's a rebel who doesn't take
no shit and he would fight back here and
die a thousand times before just
silently and politely taking this
execution longest attempted execution
ever see right now bee is fighting
against way more bad guys than he would
have been if he'd had just fought
against his captors five minutes ago
off-brand inception noise oh sorry any
sins the last couple minutes I literally
quit watching this is already the most
successful human attack on transformers
ever I mean how does he active even
beginning to bring Cybertron into our
airspace not throw the whole solar
system into orbital chaos oh no you
don't actually where were these assholes
the whole time the Decepticons were
getting their asses kicked she sure is
pretty
impolite debris also Jesus oh you'll
want to bring Sentinel back not clearly
he has all the power
what's worse that Megatron Falls for the
reverse psychology or that this movie is
still leaning on such over use cliches
at the to our 19 minute mark after three
damn movies one which included these two
fighting for 10 damn minutes Optimus
Prime takes out Megatron once and for
all with the absolute greatest of ease
you didn't betray me
you betrayed yourself blah blah me blah
blah yourself cliche it's not a Michael
Bay movie if two people aren't hugging
each other in slow motion at the end of
it I wonder what Optimus has to say
about all this a war no wait I really
mean that
John I'm pretty sure this means you
won't be in the future
the pillars for space breach I designed
and there's more to life than a little
money Anna yes for resources for
Refugees and here you are and it's a
beautiful day you had one job to do
surprise eggs 128 K binary encryption
code there's no escape
don't make me destroy you
please there can be only one